[Music]
liquid ass is a
stinky liquid that smells like butt
crack with hints of dead animal
so there are these guys andrew masters i
make liquid ass
alan whitman liquid ass creator head
janitor
we make the world the best stink product
and they work here this is what we call
the ass factory
they hated their jobs so they followed
their dreams and started a successful
prank product company specializing in a
really
rancid fart spray but
they needed a name i said so what we
gonna name it and he's getting ready to
sit down and he goes
i don't know liquid ass and i'm like
that's it
[Music]
then something curious happens we're
making a product
specifically for pranks at first but
then we start getting calls
from military people enter stu siegel
this guy stu ordered from us
and i've never met stu it sounds like
he's got a you know
a pretty neat business he really does
and he come up with the idea to use it
for a triage
but the fact is that it goes from prank
product to medical field
is sort of a sort of a jump
turns out there's a secondary market for
this stuff training some of the most
elite armed forces to do their jobs
we are a company that is replicates the
environment of combat
and right now we are in a set that we
built for medical training
basically before this prank fart spray
some of our best
troops and emergency medics were going
into the field completely unfamiliar
with the overwhelmingly
horrid smells of death and
disembowelment that they would probably
encounter as part of their jobs
it's a very awful smell it's something
that could actually gag a maggot
as far as i'm concerned it just smells
like liquid ass
back to these two jokers now we have a
product out there that's helping
military
training which is uh it's great you know
you know
not all heroes wear capes